while or 2017 is far from over the year
has already been stout with surprising
on-screen deaths from fan favorite two
characters who some wish had been given
the axe ages ago here are some of the
most surprising small screen killings of
the year so far and as always beware the
huge spoilers ahead Jane the virgin
that's the end of chained the virgin
second season Michael Cordero jr. was
shockingly shot in this hallway but the
beginning of season 3 offered fans a
collective sigh of relief when they
learn to manage to survive his injuries
but halfway through the season he died
of a related heart condition anyway
Michael's death itself wasn't too much
of a shock
since the narrator told viewers he would
love Jane until he drew his dying breath
first when he survived the shooting it
seemed like it at least stick around for
the rest of the season agents of shield
during season four of agents of shield
dr. Radcliffe spent much of his time
escaping the pain of real life within
the virtual reality framework he created
the episode self-control finally gave
fans a good look inside his realm of
computerized consciousness but when evil
Android ADA learned that his intentions
for the framework might not be what she
thought she slashes his wrists forcing
him to stay there this is the way the
world ends
not with a bang will he come back from
death Colson style maybe but few fans
saw this abrupt twist coming the Vampire
Diaries
fans of The Vampire Diaries were foaming
at the mouth when Enzo's Saint John's
heart was unceremoniously ripped out
near the end of the show's final season
sure his murderer Stefan Salvatore was
in Ripper mode and wasn't his whole self
again until after Bonnie injected him
with the cure but killing a ghoul
forever loved when things were just
starting to get good between them was
especially raw Stefan ultimately made up
for it by sacrificing himself so another
couple Damon and Elena could have their
happily ever after but the only thing
that made this even remotely bearable
was the fact that Enzo got to come back
in Ghost form and hang out with Bonnie
even after isn't timely passing big
little lies readers of Lee and
Moriarty's novel of the same name might
not have been surprised by Perry writes
brutal and in big little lies for those
who watched HBO's adaptation of the
story his passing was a shocker in the
very first episode of the show a death
was teased but it wasn't until the end
that fans found out to admit their maker
Clary was abusive to his wife was in the
process of passing on his most terrible
tendencies to her son and committed
sexual violence against Hal newcomer
Jane of some years before so he
definitely deserved what was coming to
him but still yells ax The Walking Dead
there's no shortage of death on The
Walking Dead but the show's seven per
season was filled with some especially
shocking death Berta thanks to the magic
of the Internet and the wareness of the
comics upon which to show his face the
brutal demises of Abraham and Glenn
weren't all together when foreseeable
however when Sasha decided to take a
suicide pill while stuffed in a coffin
before negan's dramatic showdown he was
quite surprised to find there emerge
from the box as an infected Walker who
wanted nothing more than to take a bite
out of his bottle wielding Armour gosh
you're not going to believe this crap
that sacrifice proved to be of little
use to the survivors since it was one of
negan's lackeys who took the brunt of
her brutality but still brave girl
homeland Peter Quinn endured a lot of
life-threatening things on Homeland
including a stroke getting gassed and a
struggle with alcoholism ultimately
however he gave up his life for his
country putting himself in the line of
fire to save president-elect Keene and
get her to the White House now fans
might have to learn to love a new
assassin turned hero the leftovers HBO's
always fascinating the leftovers started
its third and final season with a
literal bang when mega Bert blew the
guilty remnant to smithereens staking
younger convert Eva Murphy with her
since viewers that already believed
Eevee was dead once before her death
didn't come as much of a shock as Meg's
many fans figured she'd last through the
end of the series may be its most
shocking of a guilty remnant for gone
and the Meg was the cause well that's
not going to work Prison Break
resurrection the revival of Prison Break
appropriately titled Prison Break
resurrection revived the show with much
of the original cast intact only to kill
off one fan favorite in the fourth
episode though Paul Kellerman was
thought to be dead in season two viewers
later learned it was a cover-up
when the show returned Kellerman was a
changed man who'd hung up his gun and
was living a righteous life
unfortunately you can't put your past
behind you which was a lesson driven
home and Kellerman was killed by an
assassin arrow Malcolm Merlyn the
magician was ultimately a force of pain
and justice and his end came in the form
of noble sacrifice on the run from
Adrian chase on Lian Yu
Diaz stepped on a landmine and Malcolm
had come to the island to protect his
daughter took her place on top of the
mine allowing her to run to safety lest
the confront chases minions Malcolm took
his foot off the landmine wiping the
mouth and giving up his own life in the
process Empire the members of the lion
family often act irrationally and
destructively
which is what provides the soap opera
theatrics that make Empire so fun
perhaps there's nobody in the series
quite as unhinged as Leia
she's also never been fond of tarik the
illegitimate child of the family tarik
was just about to tell his half
the lucious about the kidnapping plots
but live with the stuff to that with a
fatal stab to the neck it's a desk that
was surprising flooding and sad because
lucious and Tariq were just beginning to
treat each other like brothers Fargo to
many viewers of the third season of FX's
Midwestern crime anthology it seemed
like Nicki Swango would be the last
person standing when all was said and
done after all the petty criminal pulled
the strings from the beginning
orchestrating the plot to extort money
from a parole officer fiance's wealthy
twin brother under then always rolling
with the punches staying a step ahead of
both the police and the bad guys when
plans went sour but even though the
crafty Nicki survived countless brushes
with death she still somehow met an
unceremonious and when she was shot by a
police officer during a roadside stand
off all these devastating demises just
go to show that when it comes to small
screen drama no one's safe from an early
exit thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check all this cool stuff
we know your love to
[Music]